practicar carro avella bajo el sol
almorzar en camiseta y ni un solo banco
público desocupado una ola de calor
atravesó Francia este mes de octubre
trayendo un clima inhabitual que genera
inquietud
es sorprendente pero sobre todo
preocupante de cara al futuro y para los
años que vienen ante esto los obreros
toman las mismas precauciones que en
verano
hidratamos más cuidamos mucho de tomar
descansos a estar pendientes de los unos
de los otros es importante porque nunca
se sabe cómo puedan reaccionar los
colegas con el calor
unas temperaturas estivales en pleno
otoño que prolongan la sequía en el país
en el sur los habitantes de seyón solo
pueden utilizar 100 litros de agua
diarios y por persona el equivalente a
una ducha de unos 7 minutos para evitar
consumir más de lo permitido y evitarse
una multa de 1500 euros algunos reciclan
el agua de lluvia
apenas se llenan un poquito como estos
bidones grandes pequeños y hago mi
reserva
el agua es un líquido Preciado Así que
cada gota cuenta
nos bañamos en un balde y este lo usamos
para lavar alguna ropa y para los
traperos
el pasado octubre quedó registrado como
el más caluroso que haya vivido Francia
en 77 años la temperatura promedio fue
de 17 grados unos tres a cuatro grados
por encima de lo normal